stitch by stitch Seema tries to start a
different life after escaping her
abusive husband and returning to her
father's home she says her family locked
her in a room and tortured her they
didn't want a divorce daughter so she
set the room on fire I thought to myself
if people see the fire and smoke the
fire department will come to my rescue I
felt like I was dying anyways but
luckily I wasn't turned by the fire
after that the police sent her to a safe
house but many victims of domestic abuse
are far from being safe in theory we
have a good system that protects women
the problem is with implementation and
culture some professionals don't have
the knowledge required to identify
victims of abuse and they don't have the
awareness to approach them with
sensitivity activists believe the system
has already failed men including 19
year-old Israel rape her family members
are accused of beating her to death
sparking approved locally and
internationally protesters say there is
tolerance of violence against women that
makes reporting abuse much more
difficult since the beginning of the
year human rights organizations say 19
women have died in suspicious
circumstances and in the draft law that
has been in the world
and aims to provide more protection for
them the Palestinian government
responded to public pressure with a
promise to adopt the law soon the
current penal law dates back to the
1960s and is criticized of being too
lenient especially when it comes to
perpetrators of violence against women
the Palestinian president has previously
introduced some amendments to the law
but loopholes still exist promoting
women's rights in Palestinian laws might
be controversial in some circles of
society and might provoke criticism to
the Pierre that they try to avoid it
back at the house
Sima has filed for divorce and custody
of her children but she can't guarantee
she'll be safe once she leaves need
every evil Jazeera the occupied West
Bank